harry and megan prince harry and meghan
markle the voice of a generation i'm
sorry to say
they just won an award they win lots of
silly words but they just won an award
from an environmental charity for making
the quote enlightened decision
to limit the number of kids they're
having so they they've said they have
two kids and that's it they're not going
to have any more kids they're not going
to be open to life they're not going to
be open to sharing
their love with one another that creates
a new person nope
they're limiting it okay a group called
population matters
is very pleased with this decision quote
in choosing and publicly declaring their
intention
to limit their family to two the duke
and duchess of sussex are helping to
ensure a better future for their
children and providing a role model for
other families
having smaller families reduces our
impact on the earth provides a better
chance for all our children their
children and future generations to
flourish on a healthy planet
we commend the duke and duchess for
taking this enlightened decision for
affirming that smaller family is also a
happy family
wrong it's just wrong so the this
comes out of this fear of overpopulation
we were told by people like paul ehrlich
very prominent
science scientist quote-unquote who
remains at stanford who still gets
lots of plaudits even today he said in
the 70s
overpopulation was going to cause mass
famine mass starvation there was no way
to avoid that
and we had to encourage contraception
and abortion
and if people wouldn't comply with it
then we had to force it upon them
seriously this kind of crazy stuff he
called for
these policies were picked up in india
and china led to
hideous abuses of people's rights led to
people being denied food or water or
access to sanitation if they continued
to have kids if they wouldn't be
sterilized
led to the one child policy which led to
a genocide in china
hideous hideous stuff and it was just bs
because you know what happened
since the time that paul ehrlich said
that overpopulation was inevitably going
to cause mass starvation
between that time and today the world
population has doubled
malnutrition is at an all-time low
people are fatter than they ever have
been
in the history of the world it's just
not true it is part of this
creepy anti-family anti-life movement
that tells you not to have kids in the
first place that tells you to kill your
kids when you have them
through abortion that tells you to
sterilize your children through
transgenderism
that it's just it all seems to redound
to the same
point wherever you see this this
anti-life thing recognize there is an
economic aspect here
that people just want to have more money
and they don't want to spend it on their
kids there is a political aspect here
it's easier to control people
if you break down the family and there's
a spiritual aspect too there's just
simply no denying it
there's there is an element of the
demonic in anything that tells you
not to have kids to kill your kids to
have a small family to not raise your
kids right to sterilize your kids
there's something it's not enough to
just talk about the political and the
economic
there's something spiritual there as
well hold up
i'm glad you liked that clip go check
out the full episode it's called the
perpetual revolution you can get it here
on youtube you ring that bell you
subscribe you get the notifications
you can get it on apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher myspace saying a
live journal wherever wherever you get
your podcasts
we have got a revolution going on here
folks we are going to upend
the ruling dominant desiccated corrupt
liberal regime
but we need your help to do it go check
out all that stuff and viva siempre
la revolucion
you